Good morning, everybody.
Today, I'm going to talk about public relations research.
Let's start by defining terms.
Firstly, what is research?
The Cambridge International Dictionary of English defines research as...
..."the detailed study of a subject in order to...
...discover new information or reach a new understanding."
Secondly, what do we mean by public relations research?
The Dictionary of Public Relations Measurement and Research describes it as...
..."a communication activity used for gathering information or data."
It looks at the communication relationships that exist...
...between institutions and their target market or audiences.
In seeking answers to their questions, researchers gather...
...facts and opinions on an identified issue, need or question.
As the name implies, PR research focuses on the whole PR process.
It involves the controlled, objective and systematic gathering of data, and its interpretation.
In other words, the method of collecting the data should be...
...organized, planned, managed and impartial.
In today's lecture, we'll look first at the main sources of data,...
...and then we'll look at data collection methods.